I said it before I'll say it again
tonight King Charles has stripped them
all their remaining titles and cast them
out from any connection to the royal
family any of them trusts them as far as
I could throw them
Harry and Megan the dreariest couple in
the history of planet Earth
famously abandoned their Royal duties
for a life of privacy they left the
Goldfish bowl of Great Britain for the
camouflage of California remember
famously sheltered from the evil British
press and since then they've kept an
incredibly low profile as they vowed to
if you excuse the massive book deals the
Silicon Valley startups the preaching
videos about well-being the podcast the
speeches and the major Network
interviews with everyone from Oprah
Winfrey to James Corden but it barely
been seen or heard at all have they well
on Thursday they'll quietly and
apologetically release their 100 million
dollar documentary series on Netflix the
sanctimony the fake drama the hammy woe
is me that's been going on now for years
the somber tickle of the piano geezy
staged black and white photographs of
this very ordinary young oppressed
couple
having what appears to be some tiny
semblance of fun in their California
Mansion as they count all their money
well today's new trailer doubles down on
the last trailer and there's more tears
remember that clip of Megan watch
showing us how she could cry like that
at the drop of a little tiny tarnished
Tiara remember that she could do it like
that
just bear that in mind when you watch it
did you get a one
and that's not a shameful comparisons of
Princess Diana
I remember Prince Harry being very very
angry about the media exploiting his
mother for commercial game yeah what has
he done with this Netflix series he's
used his mother to sell it
could there be a more grotesque
exploitation or a more hypocritical one
than him using his Dead Mother's imagery
to engender sympathy for himself again
as the great victim in this world you'll
claim that you're the victims of a dirty
game is especially Brazen given that
these trailers have been released to
deliberately overshadow a visit by the
prince of Princess of Wales the United
States
the timing of course is Unforgettable
unforgivable if entirely unsurprising a
typically cynical ploy to overshadow a
vitally important Royal tool the first
since the death of Queen Elizabeth what
about his father in all this a man who's
not even been coronated as king yet
still mourning the death of his mother
is he going to cop it in this series you
can bet your life you will Charles is
going to have to take it again from his
son with no ability to speak out and
return fire
this series will do great numbers for
Netflix
but maybe not for the reasons they hoped
the Oxford English Dictionary defines
hate watching the activity of watching
for the sake of enjoyment derived from
mocking or criticizing that's a measure
of success Harry and Megan you're going
to have a Smash Hit but of course a real
much of success for both of them will be
the same as it always has been how much
damage can they inflict on our royal
family on our monarchy how can they make
it all about them how can they continue
to play the victims when they live in
such unparalleled luxury the other side
of the world
this gruesome twosome only survived by
cashing in on what's left of their Royal
status now
I said it before I'll say it again
tonight King Charles should strip them
all their remaining titles and cast them
out from any connection to the royal
family any of them trusts them as far as
I could throw them because without it
they're just whining Millennial wind
bags with a permanent victim complex
knowing that victim mode is what makes
them all the money well Harry and
Megan's Netflix series released to the
world this morning is packed with well
not really Revelations are they sort of
rehashed old Revelations with a new
twist as it turns out we've apparently
been wrong all along Britain is a nasty
racist hell hole where only magnificent
Megan stood up to all this and the
world's biggest victims are not the
people of Ukraine or the people battling
covid or people struggling in a
devastating cost of living crisis no the
world's biggest victims right now are
the Duke and Duchess of Netflix nobody
set out to destroy you uh you destroyed
yourselves in this country with your
ludicrous hypocritical Behavior the
truth be told what she just said is
completely not a garbage Harry and
Megan's romance engagement and marriage
were all good with ecstatic Joy by the
British media the public and the royal
family that they've all now abandoned
that's the truth not Harry and Megan's
truth but the actual truth the first
three hours of this Netflix series
painted very different far uglier
picture of this country and our royal
family yep we're all racists apparently
sounds like a different country but
let's be clear Britain's one of the most
tolerant and Multicultural nations in
the world we celebrated the Glamorous
modern Flair of new Young Royals we
eulogize the newly biracial monarchies
the fresh face of 21st century Britain I
wrote newspaper columns about it myself
including on the day of the wedding the
press and public only turned on Harry
and Megan when their behavior became
obnoxious self-serving and rankedly
hypocritical sadly millions of people
around the world will watch this series
and they'll believe it they'll believe
the smears about Britain and our
monarchy that we're a bunch of bigoted
and hateful people they even blamed
brexit for the racism which apparently
was aimed at Meghan Markle which is just
completely absurd but by far the most
sickening part of this show for me was
the constant use of Harry's late mother
Princess Diana to stoke sympathy for
Megan having known both women Princess
Diana and Meghan Markle you can say with
absolute certainty they're nothing in
common whatsoever I couldn't think of
two women more different when it comes
to passion and empathy where's Megan's
been for her own father she completely
disowned him as she did all her wedding
actually before the wedding
as this series makes clear
he just suffered a stroke a few months
ago
missed compassion hasn't even bothered
to call her father to ask how he is and
the answer is we'll find out tonight
from his son Thomas is he's not well at
all
Harry's never even met the man whose
daughter he married doesn't care Mr
empathy Mr compassion
yet this man Thomas Markle raised Megan
on his own for many years that wasn't in
the documentary that was glossed over
that was ignored
just like he is now he lives 70 miles
away from them it's about an hour long
cab ride never seen his Grand
grandchildren this show is packed with a
kind of spurious
claims and hypocrisy to become the
Sussex signature we learned they began
making videos about the heroic Journey
six months before my Netflix deal was
even announced and right at the start of
a pandemic it was killing thousands of
people every day they're only concern
was their own situation how mean
everyone was being to them not thousands
of people dying in the streets
clearly this is all planned from the
start the show opens with the claim the
royal family declined to come and in
fact they say no one bothered to ask
them of course their biggest complaints
are as always about the terrible media
give me one good reason why we shouldn't
be feeling this way about these okay you
know what I'm going to start with the
first point because I've had to listen
to a load of people villify this woman
all day every day and you know what I'm
fed up with it so first points okay so
the commercialization of the rift within
the royal family is a byproduct okay a
byproduct of the institution's failure
to be anti-racist and Cooperative which
is ultimately led to a series of Savvy
business Stills and strategic Maneuvers
on their parts in order to ensure the
safety and security of their family what
you both fail to understand secondly
institutionalized racism when pertaining
to institutionalized racism when an
individual needs help try to seek help
and realize that there is no one to turn
to what you'll often find and you should
know this as a journalist what you often
find is that person will seek solace in
the media and presidents
hold on in an attempt to Garner support
build awareness understanding and
Inspire action and all of these typical
circumstances would be perfectly okay
but for some reason it's not with but we
don't disagree with that we don't
disagreement should be okay hold on a
second it's not for this particular
couple now hold on let's just bear that
in mind I want to ask you one thing
about what you just said okay where is
the evidence that she went to people at
the palace and they refused to give her
help who were these people nearly two
years later we still don't have any
names okay nothing right now you're
holding on to the fact that she won't
give names and I've already told you
that I think she's alive hold on a
second right I think she's a better face
saying that she's alive yes but right so
let me just say this firstly she said
her son
she said well I'm going to say why I
call her a liar she said to Oprah
Winfrey her son had not been made a
prince because of his skin color
absolute line okay so that this is what
okay by virtue of the fact that you've
come out with that uh opinion or thought
it shows me that you have a very
rudimentary understanding of racism so
let me break it down to both of you hold
on a second no hold on a second hold on
a second
institution Okay the reason why
institutions are able to perpetuate
racism is because they rely heavily on
Covert racism which is hard to prove
therefore it thrives let me just break
it down some more because you clearly
don't understand covert racism is racial
Prejudice that is subtle and discreet
and often uh disguised and rationalized
with an alternative explanation
I will give you an example I saw that
openly I would jump in I would say
100 I think any normal what do you mean
that's not right that's not right racism
full stop it should be Stamped Out
absolutely understand it by virtue of
the fact
but I do understand you don't understand
one thing
perpetuated
but you're getting into the nitty-gritty
of things now what nitty-gritty
excuse me
my show your show here's my point my
point about Megan and Harry they say all
this stuff without producing any
evidence and you wouldn't support it but
you wouldn't let me finish I've already
just explained to you covert racism is
racial Prejudice that is uh uh subtle
and discreet hold on a second no but
this is
let me explain this is what I'm trying
to explain to you and you won't let me
finish so let me finish you'll be able
to raise your point okay okay so
racial prejudice
that is subtle and discrete called
covert racism hold on listen just
listening
peers are not understanding because the
reality is I can give you an example
because clearly you're not getting it so
someone can come along and say oh I
don't like Megan because she's this
she's that she's a lie she's this she's
that when the reality is secretly it's
actually hold on a second let me finish
please answer it's actually due to the
fact that Harry who was a royal ended up
marrying a woman from the black
community but you cannot say that out
loud because that has got nothing to do
with oh it is
calm down listen because you won't
listen You'll wait for the next hour
right here's my point about that nothing
I've ever said that's critical of Meghan
Markle has anything to do with her skin
color okay so at best either subliminal
or overt or any other way is to do with
her hypocrisy and her life
also think she's a fake well joining me
now is animal Rebellion spokesman Nathan
McGovern I I don't like vegans very much
I don't think any of you are very
healthy I'm not surprised by that yeah I
think you all look pretty pasty-faced
and unhealthy to me um but that's your
choice what I don't do is I don't go
running into vegan restaurants and start
screaming abuse at you all and have to
be pulled out by people because you're
ruining everyone's fun why do you do
that to meat eaters
well Piers you've started on an absolute
blind today I actually brought a little
game with me for the me Aldo perhaps the
audience to play it's a Piers Morgan a
vegan Bingo maybe we could zoom on that
from the camera and you've actually just
ticked off wanna straight away I'll just
go with that with looking at row or a
column already so the thing is
within years
technology like Precision fermentation
you know alt protein is going to produce
the exact same products that you love
right now using a fraction of the land
producing a fraction
it's the exact same product no but I
like you to me fine you know you'll be
in the exact same product in fact the
more the more meat I want to eat I am
going to start running into vegan
restaurants
and so you can't eat your gruel and just
see how you look like it I'm gonna go to
your house and Shop paint it all over it
yes
you've got a right price oh you've got
me another one dig it off your bingo
plastic
but where's the salt where's where's it
I don't need any of this gruel yeah to
one side but I will have a bit of steak
just to you didn't salt it though you
see all you've achieved is you've made
me want to do this just actually
absolutely fine
you go for it
[Music]
do you know do you know how many steaks
he's had from my restaurant yeah a lot a
lot a lot but here's my point
I love eating steak I'm not going to
stop eating steak Yeah and the the very
last thing on Earth that will stop
meeting state is people like you with
your pasty faces running into our
restaurants telling us to stop eating
steak that's the very last thing
absolutely because you don't represent
to me Vitality or good health you're
just all alone you want a good bit of
steak that's absolutely fine you're
fully entitled to that opinion and as
I've just said earlier you're right to
protest if you want to run into your
mates are also the extinction Rebellion
right
my mates you're all like interwoven like
you said before we came on like a like a
wool and blank well are you connected or
not so we're a sister movement assistant
what's that Rebellion sounds a bit sexy
we have you know Common goals you know
irritating people
such as tackling the climate and
ecological emergencies which you know
I'm sure all of us what did you think of
Megan and Harry using a private plane
there we go Meghan Markle that's another
one four for nine now I'm not going to
give you that what did you think of them
using a private plane to go to this uh
awards show
you don't want to read a headline
tomorrow saying Nathan McGovern from
animal Rebellion slams Megan and Harry
for using private plane you don't want
to say it because like them you're a
flaming hypocrite you'd rather go in
there we go you've got me a column you'd
rather go faster you'd rather go into
restaurants like Aldos or salt Bays or
whatever and just make a nuisance of
yourselves because you it's easier